[Music]
where did you go in China where did we
go and try went to Shanghai actually we
went to the Shanghai the Shanghai Museum
of sex really yeah yeah yeah
I didn't know there's a museum of sex
there is it gonna theme to this night
show isn't it yeah well Chelsea started
anyone yeah there is there is I've
actually been to it twice I've been to
Shanghai twice and I've made a return
visit there's so many places to go in
Shanghai and you know wait well I'm just
imagining and twice you've gone to the
sex museum yeah this is an interesting
facet of your personality yes what's
going on at the sex museum what's there
um lots of weird objects that you know
you read the little blurb underneath and
it shows you that it's a some form of
sex instrument and then you look at it
and you don't really understand how it
could be used so your imagination runs
riot and why in a museum is it are these
like ancient says they're ancient and we
know they're ancient yeah yeah yeah
ancient sex objects and kind of very
very imagine precious Ming sex furniture
tell me what a mean first of all I don't
think it was the memoirs that if you go
near it it can't be it will break this
Ming sex furniture look like what does
it look like that I can tell you I
thought you're gonna ask me how it works
well if you tell me what it looks like
I'll tell you how it works exactly how
it looks and I'll tell you how it works
you know my being sex furniture well the
thing is it doesn't it looks like very
elaborate garden furniture that's that's
the best way I can describe it like you
know where you kind of you want to be
really comfortable you can it's not just
regular furniture I'm suspicious a
chaise lounge my ex Museum no my - is
that there's just a pervy archaeologist
who anything he finds he finds like a
bar on his I guess
a 7,000 year old dildo you know that's
wise that's a beautiful flower bud it's
it's like you've been to the museum yes
yeah do you ever just look at something
and it's like it's clearly just a
polished Rock and he's like now that's
um that it's all very it's exactly that
it's very ancient and then you get to
the end and there's a kind of strange
attempt to contemporize it a little bit
and that's a kind of cheesy you know in
the 80s you'd go to there were poster
stores we could buy posters you're a
kind of topless guys on a car and the
lady scratching her bomb in a tennis
playing tennis
yeah I had the topless guy right yeah
right well there was there's one of
those at the end of the sex museum he
said there's two guys and the caption
just says of the gays that's the exhibit
yeah like it's a couple of guys that
well you know the gays of course yeah
there they are those two guys yeah Wow
and can you buy that poster in the gift
shop we'll get you the post